you ready oh yeah
it'll kill
[Music]
a barbarian sword
oh yeah
weapons like this sword pay homage to
classic barbarian fantasy films and the
uncivilized and savage warriors of
history who inspired them
the long stout sword is simple in design
but it's a violent hacking and slashing
weapon due to its lightweight and sharp
double edge
perhaps most famously featured in the
film conan the barbarian this sword is
ideally suited to the ruthless and
frenzied fighting style brought to life
in these films
placements to find out what kind of
lethal damage your weapon will do i will
take your barbarian sword and lovingly
caress the edge on the torso
pierce its soul with its tip
basically the barbaric way
michael you're upwards you ready oh yeah
oh my god
jesus
mike
just the movement alone in the balance
of your blade allows for deep crushing
cuts
not only does it cut the skin it goes
into the bone and into the organs right
behind it
your weapon sir
will definitely
kill
good job thank you
all right ethan you ready let's do it
[Music]
two
[Music]
now ethan let's talk about your
barbarian sword the balance and the
weight
it's unbelievable
it feels that you can wield it
continuously and move around this is
what you want to carry into battle
is strong enough and sharp enough to
lacerate into the chest
break the bones and get into the organs
because of that
it will kill
gentlemen welcome to the strength test
the answer to the riddle in this steel
lies in the correct edge geometry and
heat treat and to test those things as
well as the overall construction of your
swords i'm going to be bashing away on
this battering ram
remember this test is all about what the
ram does to your swords and not what the
swords do to the ramp
michael you're up first you ready oh
yeah let's go
michael
this is so much fun to swing
there's
no edge deformation that i can see at
all the handle is comfortable the only
thing i could say at all is that the
cross guard has some sharp corners here
and they kind of bit into my fingers as
i was swinging it
but aside from that it's a wonderful
sword well done thank you
ethan are you ready
let's do it let's do it
wow
this thing is amazing it's light it's
beautifully balanced it was easy to
control
took no damage i love that i can choke
right up to the guard here and it's just
super comfortable the whole time
really well done
i just did all right gentlemen it's time
for the sharpness test
you ready let's go all right michael
nice
all right michael
when i made that first punch through the
skin i was expecting some resistance and
there wasn't any
your edge is beautiful
your guard i mean i kind of like the way
you've got that sort of an s shape to it
but it bites a little bit on the hand
but uh this is a sword that you could
just play with all day long nicely done
all right ethan you're up are you ready
let's do it okay
[Music]
uh
so
this sword
it's light it's fast
the balance is right back here in my
hand nothing's pulling the tip i know
exactly where the tip is the cuts are
beautiful
sharp blade it's a great cutter nicely
done
thank you
[Music]
michael ethan this was not an easy
decision but a decision has been made
the forged and fire champion is
ethan
good job
michael
i don't want to say your blade didn't
make the cut because it definitely cuts
but
in this particular case you're not the
fortune fire champion
michael
you brought us an amazing barbarian
sword you should be proud it came down
to the finer details balance comfort
ounces of weight ethan won
you didn't lose
michael the craftsmanship on that blade
is incredible please give it to me
[Laughter]
i'm feeling disappointed a little little
deflated but at the same time i
i think i did well
it's a tough competition and i'm really
proud of myself
ethan congratulations you are the forge
and fire champion and that is a title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars
please present your weapon to the judges
wow i don't know what to say
it's a very humbling feeling to know
that i want a competition against an
awesome sword and
excellent bladesmith
never stop pursuing your dreams no
matter how crazy they are because
of all the dreams i'm going after this
is just the beginning
[Music]
the united states air force
non-commissioned officer sword
despite having no historical use of
swords the u.s air force utilizes
ceremonial weapons like the
non-commissioned officer sword as a nod
to their roots in the army
based on the european pillow sword the
nco is a lightning fast stabbing weapon
that can be unleashed with lethal
precision in able hands small lobed
quillions form the nco's cross garden
its flattened blade extends to a point
about 28 inches away
the nco sword's sleek design is the
ideal symbol for the air force's
stealthy enemy vanquishing power all
right airmen now we'll take your weapon
and deliver some thrust and slashes on
this ballistics
mike you're up first you ready
absolutely let's do it
cool
all right mike
it's a very light sword because of that
you can move with it
now your tip allows for a nice thrust
with your edge it slices i can feel
every cut in there but more importantly
it will kill
thank you all right matt your turn you
ready sir yes sir
nice
all right mats talk about your blade
here
the edge that you have here is very
sharp the point
punctures nicely and most importantly
sir
it'll kill awesome thank you
all right next stop the strength test
for that we have ben
hello bladesmiths to test the strength
and durability of your swords as well as
their overall construction i'll be
bashing them into this propeller
mike you're up first you ready
no
we're gonna do it anyway all right
well mike your blade helds up great the
only issue i have with it is that i
would really like this pommel to be
bigger if the pommel were bigger it
would give me a stop but it's got a nice
weight it's still sharp as when it
started really well done thank you so
much matt you're up what are you
thinking ready all right
[Music]
[Music]
well matt your blade
held up great
it's still sharp
this is a much heavier sword but the
biggest issue i have is with the cross
card in back your cross guard is loose
it wiggles and also your wire wrap is
loose
but
it's all in one piece it did a heck of a
thing on that propeller well done thank
you when we're not finished yet next up
is the sharpness test and for that i
give you to doug
all right airmen to test the edge of
your blade i'm going to be cutting
across these harnesses
i'm looking for clean cuts
mike you're up first you ready for this
let's do it
do this
[Music]
all right mike
light and flight and sharp enough to cut
through the harness it will cut thanks
sir good job thanks man
all right matt your turn sir are you
ready yes sir let's do this i need my
blade to cut right through these straps
like butter
all right matt let's talk about your
blade here it's kind of heavy
it's so forward in its weight that on
this slash you see the last six inches
it just scratched the back of the
harness but on the backhand swing where
it's going all the way through it cut
the harness
but your weapon sir it will cut thanks
good job man thanks coming into this
matt and i promised each other that our
goal was to make each other earn it he's
a heck of a smith so it's in the judge's
hands now
mike matt the judge's deliberation is
complete they've made their final
decision about which of you will move
forward to our battle of the branch's
final competition to represent the air
force at the air force's anvil the blade
smith moving forward is
mike congratulations
thank you
matt at this time i have to ask you to
please surrender your blade
i feel good no matter what i mean i'm
glad i made it here good job thank you
i'm proud of myself for sure
how do you feel feels amazing
please present your blade to the judges
i can't believe i'm the air force
champion i'm looking forward to showing
the rest of the dod what we've got
there's a lot of added pressure moving
forward now i'm competing against the
army the navy and the marine corps and
we've got a little bit of a rivalry
going on so you better bring it because
you know i'm going to
the m1832 foot artillery sword
the m18 32-foot artillery sword is the
american recreation of a french
artillery sword modeled after the
infamous roman gladius
featuring a short and stout blade the
weapon has an ornate handle cast
entirely of brass
feathers or scales are traditionally
molded into the handle and an eagle is
etched into the pommel to honor america
produced through the end of the 19th
century the m1832 was issued to
artillerymen but more widely used to
clear paths through thick brush than as
the last minute lifesaver
when called upon the sword was lethal in
close quarters and was employed by
disemboweling horses to bring down the
rider who then was finished in quick
fashion
to find out what kind of deadly force
your artillery resorts could supply i
will take your weapon deliver killing
slashes on this ballistics dummy
got me up first you ready for this ready
all right john first up i like the
beauty of an all-metal construction and
the damascus pattern you have here is
gorgeous the weight is all the way in
the handle allows for a good recovery
and forward delivery of strikes your
edges are very sharp every cut cuts deep
cuts the bone and into the organs and
most importantly sir
it will kill thank you
all right tommy your turn you ready get
her done
[Music]
all right tommy let's talk about your
weapon here it is a beast the weight of
your weapon is all forward that it
actually takes a lot to pull it away for
a second strike but the thing that your
beast does have is a very sharp edge
every cut is very deep but it takes a
lot of work to control this beast more
importantly though sir
it will heal
[Music]
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test now why bring swords to a
gun range well so you too can join one
of our two clubs they oh my god they
broke my blade with the bullet club
or the bulletproof sword club so to test
your blades we've got our firearm locked
in a vise we've got your blade locked
another vice downrange we're gonna fire
one round at that thing it should split
that bullet clean or worst of all see
that blade shatter
john you're up first are you ready for
this yep
fire
four holes
i thought i felt that you lost a hair of
edge
that's bullet hung up on the blade
awesome you can actually see top and
bottom where that bullet went across
your blade now you can see there's four
holes in the thing over there that's the
lead core and the jacket going in
different directions so you split that
bullet nicely i don't see any damage to
your blade well done good job thank you
all right tommy are you ready for this
let's do it
my blade is stouter it's bigger and it's
battery i expected to stand up to this
bullet shoot
it
fire
there we go
all right tommy well your blade took
some damage in that bullet test there's
a chip in one spot and the other spot
you can actually
hear my fingernail catching on that roll
having said that it doesn't feel bad in
my hand but it is very heavy for this
type of sword but as far as the strength
test goes as you can clearly see
you took some damage
[Music]
all right bladesmiths now that we know
your blades can take a bullet it's time
to find out they can cut this is the
sharpest test
the shot bag slice
now unlike the strength desk this is all
about what the edge of your blade will
do to these shot bags a sharp blade
should cut cleanly john you're up first
you ready for this yep let's do this
gentlemen this is what i love about your
blade the balance it is fun to wield it
is fun to move around it cuts with every
slice
it will cut
thank you
all right tommy it's your turn sir you
ready let's do it i feel like i'm a
little behind i took some damage in the
last test and i really need to
outperform now in order to win
awesome
all right tommy on the stationary cuts
it cuts cleanly it's a sharp blade now
when i'm moving around and changing my
balance because of the weight of the
blade it does affect the way i'm cutting
so some of the cuts are not clean all
the way through there's some strands
more importantly your weapon here though
a beast
it will cut
john tommy the judges have made their
final decision
our new fortune fire champion is
[Music]
john congratulations you're the forge
and fire champion tommy unfortunately
your blade didn't make the cut please
leave the range
thank you sir thank you
i completely agree with the outcome john
made a better sword beauty overcame the
beast in the situation and he deserves
it john congratulations you are the
force and fire champion and that is the
title that comes with the check for ten
thousand dollars good job brother thank
you
feels great to be the next fortune fire
champion good job now i'm super proud of
all the work that i've done i've come
here and done tests that i've never
would have expected put myself into
challenges that i never would have tried
before and
i've succeeded so i feel awesome
the xi'an sword first appeared in china
all the way back in the 7th century bc
vc
wisely designed the sharp lethal tip was
ideal for rapid cuts and stabs while the
wide body aided in deflecting attacks
considered an elite weapon due to the
amount of training needed to master the
sword the straight double-edged blade
was built for subtle instant strikes
requiring a level of precision in
finesse that only comes from a true
swordsman
because it was so difficult to master
the xi'an was removed in mass from the
battlefield however many are still
involved in ceremonies and featured in
films including crouching tiger hidden
dragon
all right bladesmiths welcome to kill
test
now your giant swords look beautiful but
are they deadly well to find that out i
will take your weapon and do some
slashes and thrust on this ballistic
dummy
vince here first you ready gabriel
all right vince let's talk about your
jion sword up here
overall
i like the aesthetics of this sword
now your handle construction
is within scale of this blade it's
comfortable when i wrap around it
now your edge
is razor sharp in thrusting it cuts out
and when you swing you can feel the
impact of this sword overall sir
it'll keel
wanted to hear that
good job
hey casey you got the stomach for this
you're next i'm ready
[Music]
all right casey let's talk about your
giant sword here
first up i like the lines that you have
with your sword here
and the damascus pattern i can
appreciate that
and now
in cutting it was so much fun just to be
able to slice
over and over and over
with ease with a blade that moves
this sir
will kill thank you
bladesmiths welcome to the strength test
now to test the edge holding ability of
your blades and the overall strength and
construction i'm going to take each of
your swords
and smash them repeatedly into these
heavy pots now
i'm not really concerned what your
blades do to the pots even though it's
going to look really cool and be a lot
of fun i want to see what the pots are
going to your blades and edges
vince you're up first you ready to go
yes sir
oh vents like i tell you it's a great
blade
i mean where i was striking is still
sharp
still straight and true
but the problem is
doing your pommel
your threads here
didn't go very far through so pummel
broke loose
bit of a problem
vince your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure after three shots
on the pots a pummel is critical to a
one-handed weapons retention but that
doesn't mean that this competition is
over casey
these are some pretty strong terra cotta
pots and you'll have to survive three
pot shots to make it out of here i feel
ready all right jay you ready
if the pots can knock off the pommel
they could do anything it all comes down
to this got a little bit of knots in my
stomach let's see what happens
looks good
casey congratulations your blade
survived vince
unfortunately you cannot continue
testing please exit the forge
i'm disappointed i think i made a hell
of a blade it was still sharp after the
three terracottas
but the blade needs to be a hundred
percent
mine was 98
and he failed casey congratulations you
are the forge and fire champion and
that's the title that comes with a check
for 10 000 big ones buddy
congratulations
thank you
deed is done
and i won
great steel and a great job on a handle
too i've proven to myself
that i can make a damn good blade for me
that's nothing better
deer horn knives
whoa
deer horn knives are distinctive
double-bladed weapons used as an
extension of the body to counter and
disarm opponents the knives are unique
to the 19th century martial art form fog
young students of this discipline train
with the weapon in both hands to master
techniques in slashing and seizing
easily concealed in traditional chinese
garb these mighty knives can be swiftly
brandished to catch an opponent off
guard and deliver deadly cuts with four
horn shaped points the weapons are
notably employed in the film crouching
tiger hidden dragon
to see how lethal your weapon is i will
deliver multiple slashes and thrust on
this pig carcass
steve you're up first you ready
absolutely let's do this
[Music]
oh
well steve you know i was surprised
being that you only have a scale on one
side for the handle and none of the
other it is a rustic look but
nonetheless it is actually comfortable
to hold on to your tips over there sharp
enough to cut easy to thrust with the
bottom and deliver a slice at the same
time
overall
your weapon
will kill
yeah
all right nick you're next are you ready
oh yeah
well nick your weapon is very sharp
grabbing your handle it feels smooth
with both scales in there the angles you
have
really
lacerate deeply and overall your weapon
will
kill
good job thank you next up is a
sharpness test to see how sharp your
weapons are i will take your weapons and
deliver multiple slashes and stabs on
this ballistic bag the bag is outfitted
with two posts which simulates blocks or
blows from pole weapons these knives
will encounter in battle
steve you're first you ready yes i am
well steve the points are sharp they
lacerate cleanly it feels good in the
hand i can maneuver this sir will cut
thank you nick you're up next you ready
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm pretty confident
mine can do at least that well probably
better because my points are more
pointier
[Music]
well you can see that it penetrates deep
the angles you have them in and
lacerates out they're comfortable in the
hand and your blades
will cut
thank you next up is strength test tape
to test the strength of your weapons
we're going to clamp them into our
contraption back here once triggered a
staff will strike the center section of
each of the blades one time with a force
of 2000 pounds
simulating the kind of attacks these
weapons could historically encounter in
combat
steve are you ready yes i am three
two
one
in three
two one
yeah well steve i don't see any damage
any rolling of the edge so they held up
beautifully that's great
nick
just waiting for it waiting for it and
one
two
three
and it broke the stick
three
two
one
[Music]
and it broke the stick again
all right well first off let's remember
that the test wasn't about breaking
sticks it was more about how your blade
reacts to being hit by that stick
there is
no damage whatsoever this is still a
razor blade
oh nicely done thank you well you've
both done commendable work but there can
only be one forged and fire champion in
this competition
[Music]
nick
congratulations you are the forest and
fire champion
steve it's that time please surrender
your weapons congratulations i'm not
surprised at the result there is a
natural
energy that guides all of us throughout
our lives and this is how everything
naturally unfolded unfortunately it
didn't go my way this time but but i'll
be back
nick congratulations you're the fortune
fire champion and we'll be receiving a
check for ten thousand dollars how do
you feel
darn good
awesome good job brother
that's me
that's me the nick that's me i won
i'm gonna hug my wife when i get home
and then i'm gonna hug my kitty cat if
any of you other bladesmiths out there
are thinking about it and i say do it
try not to have a cold when you do it
though
the touareg tacoba
the tacova is a type of broadsword that
has been used by the nomadic taureg
people of north africa since the 14th
century
this double-edged lightweight blade was
carried for self-defense on long
journeys designed to deliver lethal
slashes and stabs against a rival
warrior
due to the torg's aversion to iron there
is no exposed steel or iron on the hilt
of this sword so it cannot touch the
user's hand measuring more than a meter
long this deadly weapon was seen as a
symbol of wealth some members of the
tacoba clan still carry this weapon
today
bladesmiths welcome to the keel test
your terrechticobus look beautiful but
the kind of beauty i'm looking for is
the lethal kind i'm gonna take your
weapon deliver some lethal blows in this
ballistic stubby dusting up first ready
yes sir let's do this
[Applause]
all right dustin let's talk about your
weapon here
first up your handle construction
i like the avoid feel of this the flare
you have there in your pommel actually
gives great retention for this
your tip
is sharp enough to penetrate your edges
are sharp when you're cutting out and
you can wheel this
to do that kind of damage on this
bullet's dummy
overall sir a weapon like this
it will kill
awesome
all right joshua your turn you ready
keep everyone alive all right let's do
this
all right joshua let's talk about your
weapon here your pommel right here could
have used some weight to it but because
it's forward weighted and the fact that
you have a very sharp edge every slice
that you can see is very deep into the
ballistics dummy and more importantly
sir your weapon
your keel
girl
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test our desert well chop
now to test the strength and overall
construction of your blades i will be
chopping into our well house as well as
the well and dustin you're on deck you
ready
i guess so
okay
oh
[Music]
all right
we were doing so well for a moment there
what actually happened was
with insetting your blade
down into this piece of wood
any of that leverage was just too much
for the wood itself and it popped it
loose
your tang is a little bit small but what
i do like to see is that your blade
actually held up beautifully
i mean your grain structure looks fine
this is an absolutely brutal test it's
very well done thank you
now dustin you survived every one of the
strikes except for the last one your
guard gave way and your blade fallout so
we consider this a catastrophic failure
you cannot continue testing your blade
but you're not out of the fight yet how
you feeling joshua
pressure's on all right so you need to
survive five strikes in order to be
named forged and fire champion you ready
yes sir all right let's do it
well joshua your blade is strong it made
it past all the strikes congratulations
now dustin unfortunately for you that
means your time here in this competition
has ended because you did have a
catastrophic failure it was an honor
watching you in our forge but
unfortunately man at this time i'm gonna
have to ask you to please step off our
forged floor
thank you guys thank you so much i'm
definitely crushed i actually thought
that recessing the sword into the tang a
little bit would make it stronger and
that's kind of what bit me in the end so
definitely definitely won't be doing
that again
i'm definitely proud of this blade
i came here to challenge myself as much
as i could and i definitely achieved
that
well joshua congratulations man that
means you are the newest fortune fire
champion you just got yourself a check
for ten thousand dollars congratulations
[Applause]
yeah
oh my gosh i made a sword it didn't
break oh my gosh it was a hard
competition so this is unreal
[Music]
the quora
the korra sword originated in nepal
where it was wielded for centuries by a
legendary group of soldiers the gurkhas
the gurkhas were known for their
fearless military prowess and weapons
based martial arts which included
symbolic weaponry like the cora sword
this fearsome sword features a long
curved blade that flares outward at the
tip maximizing the force of each swing
and making it an ideal weapon for both
slashing and chopping
also used in sacrifice a skilled coral
wielder could reportedly cut a sheep in
half with just one swing
the nepalese cora was a blade that had a
distinct inward curved and spatulated
flare at the tip making it a weapon for
slicing and chopping now we'll cut
across these sandbags let's see how
sharp your blades are
josh you're up first you ready i'm ready
let's do it
josh great balance
the blade really wants to chop and slice
the recovery on the blade makes it one
that wants to continue for combat one
problem i have here is this handle it
tends to roll but other than that
it will cut good job sir thank you
liam you're up next are you ready
when he said it this was heavy
you weren't kidding this is a chopper
a little hard to control on the recoil
but not enough to where i can't wield it
this sir
will cut
great good job
next up is a strength test
dave
gentlemen to test the strength of your
cora i'm gonna take one blow into these
skulls
josh you're up you ready i'm ready all
right fantastic
nice
josh
went right into the skull swings easy
super lightweight
but uh
like doug said the handle wants to roll
in my hand
nonetheless
nicely done thank you all right moving
on
you ready yeah okay
wow that's a beast
it feels really nice in the hand you did
a great job on this handle obviously we
pretty much took care of that skull
now this thing once you get it started
it's going to go right
my only worry is is stopping it yeah you
don't always have to have a heavy blade
to make a heavy blow
but it's a beautiful piece it's a nice
job thank you well done
liam josh both of your weapons are
spectacular but in this competition
there can only be one champion
and that champion is
liam congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion josh unfortunately
your blade did not make the cut please
surrender your weapon
i came here to challenge myself and i
came here to hopefully represent
bladesmithing well and i think i did
that liam congratulations you were the
forest and fire champion and will be
receiving a check for 10 grand good job
you are our youngest champion so far
congratulations great job good job
[Applause]
i just won fours and fire just wow
this is a big feat for me to accomplish
against master smith i think that all
the people that i went to high school
with they'll finally realize it's not
just a hobby it's something that i can
really succeed at i'm gonna use the ten
thousand dollars and just put it
straight into a new shop and uh these
are like my only pair of jeans
so maybe i'll get another pair of jeans
you